d'ailleurs on dit non et pour ou contre
la violence soit je suis contre bah
ouais mais pourquoi
en fait cela parce que la violence c'est
mal oui mais pourquoi exactement va
parce que c'est mal
[Musique]
la violence c'est mal voilà normalement
vous êtes tous plus ou moins au courant
presque tous mais au delà du principe
moral est ce que en termes de santé vous
savez pourquoi
la violence c'est mal d'abord parce que
la violence
ça fait mal car le nord mais surtout
parce que la violence ça fait du mal je
vais essayer d'être plus cher alors bien
sûr quand on pense à la violence on
pense un oeil au beurre noir mais qu'à
ses hématomes des quilles fracture
blessure en tous genres et toutes les
séquelles qui vont avec
rien que ça abîmer le corps de quelqu'un
on le frappe en ses moyens coule
complètement nul
mais on va se concentrer sur un organe
en particulier probablement le plus
sensible aux coups violents
le cerveau
le système nerveux autonome celui qui
gère le coeur la respiration la
digestion etc
il peut réagir à une douleur violente
dans ses gares et il a tendance à
s'emballer un peu il fait ralentir les
battements du coeur il dilate les
vaisseaux donc l'attention chute
résultat votre cerveau est moins bien
briguer y manque d'oxygène et pim vous
perdez connaissance ça c'est valable
pour n'importe quel type de douleur ça
marche même pour les émotions fortes
on appelle ça une syncope ou un malaise
vagal mais c'est pas tellement que ça
que j'avais envie de parler quand on
prend un coup au visage ou même sur la
tête il ya la douleur
évidemment mais il ya aussi un autre
phénomène qui rentrent en jeu le prenez
pas mal hein mais votre cerveau il prend
pas toute la place dans votre crâne du
coup en cas de choc violent
ça remue là dedans ce qui se passe avec
les ondes de choc se propage de la
surface du cerveau jusque dans ses
parties profondes et que ça peut se
ressentir sur les fonctions qu'il est
censé assurer en temps normal c'est ce
qu'on appelle une commotion cérébrale si
les structures du cerveau sont trop
secouée elle n'assume plus leur rôle
correctement et là aussi on peut perdre
connaissance
d'ailleurs si vous êtes témoin de ce
genre de scène sachez que tout coup sur
la tête
et bah ça s'appelle un traumatisme
crânien mais surtout en cas de perte de
connaissance ça vaut vraiment le coup
passer un coup de fil au 15 au 18 ou au
112 pour aller regarder d'un peu plus
près à l'hôpital et là on parlait des
coups mais c'est valable pour n'importe
quel choc au niveau de la tête
alors vous me direz ça va tomber dans
les pommes deux minutes c'est pas
méchant
ça témoigne quand même de la violence du
choc subi par le cerveau qui peut avoir
des conséquences beaucoup plus graves
mary parce que votre petit cerneaux de
noix aux abats si ça ressemble vachement
un cerneau de noix
on en a même déjà parlé votre petit
cerneaux de noix donc en plus d'être
secoué il peut se cogner contre les
parois de la boîte crânienne et comme
votre crâne c'est de l'os donc c'est dur
donc ça peut abîmer le cerveau ça peut
saigner à différents niveaux ce qui est
jamais une bonne nouvelle
et ça peut gonfler un peu comme quand
vous cogné le genou
on appelle ça un oedème cérébral sauf
que on en a déjà parlé dans la vidéo sur
l'avc vous suivez pas je suis pas
content le crâne
on a vu ces de l'os donc c'est dur mais
surtout c'est pas extensibles c'est pas
élastique
si ça saigne ou si ça gonfle le cerveau
il se retrouve comprimé le sang circule
moins bien et à la bim encore plus le
problème c'est que ce truc là ça peut
arriver super vite genre dans les heures
qui suivent mais ça se voit pas
forcément tout de suite mais j'insiste
le meilleur indice c'est la fameuse
perte de connaissance au moment du choc
donc faut vraiment prendre ça au sérieux
il faut prendre ça au sérieux parce que
dans les cas les plus graves
les saignements les oedèmes débat ça
peut entraîner la mort est parfois très
rapidement genre en une nuit et dans un
bar tu prends un coup de poing tu
rentres chez toi tu te couches le
lendemain tu travailles tu es mort c'est
évidemment pas les cas les plus
fréquents mais j'en ai quand même
rencontré quand je travaille à l'hôpital
donc fait bien et quand ils tuent pas un
choc au cerveau même léger ça peut
entraîner un certain nombre de séquelles
et encore plus quand ça se répète
régulièrement
c'est la raison pour laquelle au rugby
par exemple on a mis en place un
protocole commotion qui oblige tous les
joueurs compris un coup à la tête à se
faire évaluer tout de suite par un
médecin avec éventuellement une mise au
repos forcé en cas de perte de
connaissance
parce que quand le cerveau est malmené
de façon répétée il peut apparaître
qu'on appelle une encéphalopathie
traumatique chronique qui n'est une
récente a montré que malgré leur casque
la quasi-totalité des footballeurs
américains pro ont des dommages
cérébraux après l'arrêt de leur carrière
avec des conséquences comme des troubles
de la concentration des troubles du
comportement dès démence précoce des
dépressions voir des suicides dans le
cas de mohamed ali la légende de la boxe
de nombreux spécialistes ont fait le
lien entre la maladie parkinson qu'il a
développée à 42 ans seulement et les
chocs répétés qu'il a pris au niveau de
la tête pendant toute sa carrière et qui
ont endommagé
ces cellules nerveuses dans un autre
registre des signes d'encéphalopathie
traumatique chronique ont aussi été
repérées chez les footballeurs ou vie
ils ont un cerveau ça va deux secondes
les blagues et dans leur cas c'est juste
le jeu de tête qu'est mis en cause donc
vraiment un choc au niveau du visage de
la tête ou du crâne
ces pannes et pourtant certains sites de
self défense
n'hésite pas à balancer la liste des
points vitaux qu'on peut frapper au
niveau de la tête avec les bons gros
dommage qu'on peut espérer causer sur
vis bien tranquille c'est obtenir des
galaxies qui m'ont serré âpre en
détruire le service
alors bien sûr plus le choc est violent
comme en cas d'une chute ou d'un
accident de la route
plus les chocs sont fréquents et plus le
risque est élevé mais un truc super
important à retenir c'est que pour
provoquer des lésions cérébrales voir
pour tuer quelqu'un
un seul coup peut suffire déjà arrivé et
comme vous n'avez sans doute ni envie
que quelqu'un ni envie de vivre avec ça
sur la conscience ni de passer plusieurs
années à y réfléchir dans deux trois
mètres carrés mais le mieux c'est de ne
pas frapper les gens voient la dtcc fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là
prenez soin de votre cerveau et de celui
des autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]